attestation dérogatoire ou attestation
professionnels en ce premier week-end de
confinement c'est de pédagogie et de
discernement dont a fait preuve la
compagnie de gendarmerie de saint
germain en laye on va avoir des services
vraiment dédié à ces restrictions un
petit peu de circulation et de respect
de ces règles de confinement avec
notamment le le contrôle des
attestations puisqu'il ya trois types
d'attestation maintenant qu'ils sont
mises en place et les contrôles donc
vont être vraiment intensifiée à partir
de lundi puisque la période je dirais un
petit peu de de pédagogie pour ce
week-end et de tolérance sera passée
donc on agira sans doute avec un petit
peu plus de fermeté
mais toujours avec le discernement
nécessaire achats de première nécessité
déplacements professionnels ou médicaux
les dérogations sont sensiblement les
mêmes que lors du premier confinement
mars dernier pas toujours bien ancrée
oui c'est normal en fait je tourne et
dehors on est censé ne pas être dehors
donc c'est normal pour moi qu'est ce que
vous faisiez justement d'or en fait on
est partis mettre de l'essence
ils font leur travail là pas de souci il
faut respecter le confinement de
présentation c'est la même règle pour
tout le monde c'est normal ça ne dérange
pas c'est ils font leur travail et c'est
logique mais d'après qu est ce que j
entendis et qu'est ce que j'y vis plutôt
qui
il ya beaucoup de décès beaucoup des
gens malades et qui sont en réanimation
ce soir là la compagnie n'a pas dressé
d'amande lors du premier confinement les
forces de l'ordre avaient dressé plus
d'un million de contraventions pour plus
de 20 millions de contrôles